now you may have noticed one of the
annoying things about using input this
way is that it's distracting to have the
address bar on the screen when I'm
taking a picture one thing you might
want to do is take your app full screen
this is pretty simple to do just grab
the Dom element that you want to make
full screen that you want to be the root
of the window and call its request full
screen method now at the time of this
recording request full screen is still
vendor prefixed so we'll have to use
WebKit request full screen and mo's
request full screen one important thing
to notice here is the difference in
capitalization kind of annoying but
it'll get fixed sooner or later one
important thing to note is that you can
only call this API in the handler for a
user action like clicking on a button
this is to avoid apps forcing users into
full screen mode you can't just do this
when you're loading the page